Good morning.
Happy Thanksgiving.
We're going to do something fun today.
Now, I was planning on doing this all
day. Um, and then my family informed me
that apparently we are doing
Thanksgiving at 2 p.m. today.
So, it's going to be a little shorter
than expected, but uh we still have I
know a good
over a couple of hours to try this out
and hopefully this gives us a decent
indicator. So, the plan for today.
and then we are going to see uh how this
does
Now, I do like um I got two of the tiny
boxes behind me.
And there's some stuff about this
project I already know I like, and
there's some stuff I'm not so sure about
yet.
I'm going to be as critical as normal.
And really, the goal here is to figure
out one, if I like it, and two, if it
actually can solve any of the problems
we have.
Okay,
we can do source.
I only have UV on this.
Oops.
Hey, Jess.
Okay. How are you supposed to install
this thing?
Is this not UV compatible?
It's going to screw up my virtual amp,
isn't it?
if you make a new VN. But I have an
existing VN.
I'm in a VN. The puffer is the This is
the VN symbol right here is the puffer.
what does this say? Requirement match is
named tiny but self-dependencies.
I mean, this thing is just going to make
some [ __ ] up, I'm sure.
Okay, apparently I messed it up. What
did I mess up then? Did I literally just
do that?
Oh, UV pip install, not UV ad. Okay, UV
pip install the URL.
Fine.
My mistake.
I haven't had to use UV from direct URLs
before.
Okay.
Check the initial example.
And actually, I'm going to just swap
these two windows.
Happy Thanksgiving.
Happy Thanksgiving as well to you.
So, what we're going to want to do here
is to make
Let's start with a very simple test.
All right. Um yeah, let's start with a
very simple test.
I think the thing that we are going to
want is
we have this mining somewhere. No.
Or rather, I can just import it.
That'll be easier.
So this is the uh the architecture
that I wanted to test.
I think we have enough time to do this
full thing.
Exploration exploit trade-off.
Uh just the advice that most of the lit
in that space is very low quality. Jess
I keep my co high even if my elo delta
will be lower. You should just sweep it
and stop thinking about it.
Yeah. So let's go take this
uh fault encoder default decoder
Let's see what ops they have um built
in.
We know they have mount moles.
We can probably just get some basic
mining thing, right?
I think that's going to be the thing we
ultimately want anyways.
But would it be better to get us an
initial test first?
probably we do want a um a better
initial test first. So, let's just do
that.
And I know I don't need
excuse me I know I know I don't need to
wrap this but we're going to do other
stuff with this in a bit anyways.
debug equals two to see internals.
Cool. Um what I want to do basically let
me explain. So the very first thing I
want to do is I just want to get a um
flops throughput with uh a basic torch
model and a basic tiny model with some
relatively small nets and then we'll do
some more advanced stuff like I want to
see if we can test some of the mining
functions out and maybe even get kernel
gen depending how much time I have.
Okay. So, is there an API that looks
like this or not really?
Yes, there is.
See, I don't necessarily care too much
that you have an API like this, but it's
very good that they do have this.
In fact, this is almost exactly what we
want.
Oh, I really like that they don't have a
base class. I really really like that
they don't have a base class. This is
like Good job.
Um I do not like that they golf like
guys that like come on.
All right, there. That's better.
And screw the Python type system
there. That's better.
Hidden size.
Size. Hidden size.
Okay.
X equals
one
dot
Cool.
flatten dot rellerfect.
And we're going to do input
size equals
19 or what's it 18
as this is like a reasonable
model for RL reasonable very small model
That is slightly obnoxious
having to do this manually.
state always going to be the cheapest
way to get observations.
there are situations where the state is
really expensive and the nets that you
need to use for encoding are really hard
to optimize, but in most cases, it's
pretty good.
Let's just do
what do we do? A 4096 batch size.
Whoops.
We'll just do the supervised thing for
now.
Cheney type code is not my favorite. But
this is the thing I do like about this
is I'm pretty sure this is completely
this is completely optional, right? like
you can just do it the other way.
This is not bad so far.
So far, my only nitpick is this thing
not having uh no get params or whatever,
but that's super easy to do.
So, so far this is so good. So far so
good.
getting dype float.
Okay, so here we have our first tiny
grad error. Let's see how their errors
are.
Intensor getting type float.
That's fine.
Okay, so here we get our first
kind of jank looking error.
Let's see how their traces are. No, we
actually we don't. It's not bad cuz we
actually we do see the traces right here
in sparse categorical cross entropy. At
least
the bottom of the stack's a little
weird, but
shape.
Yeah, that's what I figured. Jess
All right. So now let's go find their
docs.
They got doc somewhere
I guess the laziness makes sense
because
it's freaking Python. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Cool.
So,
um, is it
is it two times input times hidden? Is
that that's the the flops, right?
Actually, I we can literally just do
this.
multiply accumulates is two flops. One
mole plus one add flops is max time two
board or max
* 2
M1 +
batch hidden hidden batch hidden output
and then the factor of two. Yeah, this
is what I expect.
right? It's 2x forward
backward
max equals
2 * this. Backward flops is 2 * that,
which is Yeah. Okay.
We are seeing if tiny is good.
Basically, we're going to we're playing
around with it and we're also going to
do some speed tests on small models
because you know most people testing
these libraries are testing them on much
bigger models. Um so you know hot said
um you know Tiny's quite a bit behind
Nvidia uh on Nvidia hardware for the
bigger models but then he said you know
actually this might be good on small
models. So I am testing this
and the other thing is it can out
apparently it can output kernel code
directly. So we're going to see if that
ends up being useful as well.
you know, if I can get this thing to
output kernels.
And we're doing this until probably
1:15ish today.
And then I got to go for um Thanksgiving
evidently. I thought I was going to be
here all day, but family is uh has early
Thanksgiving plans this year.
Yeah, we're doing the overall per first.
Daniel
This is going to be iters times batch
divided by and
I'll end.
What type of neural nets do you usually
use in puffer ms? Well, in puffer 3,
it's um a small encoder, small decoder
with uh the core being an LSTM. In
Puffer 4, we're looking at a mining
group based architecture and it's a
little harder to perf optimize even
though it should be much more efficient.
So, we're looking at this.
I think this is without this is without
the jet as well.
Okay,
so
uh let's see if we find Where is the
jet?
Uh, how do we do this?
This is has net as a freaking
global
which I hate but we'll do that for now
opinion about the docs. I've only been
using this for the last 30 minutes.
Arnance are for previous dates. Yes, for
memory
Okay.
And this is
tiny model.
Okay.
Forward pass.
Why don't use the PyTorch front end? I'm
just trying Tiny today.
And what is the Pi? What? What is the
PyTorch front end?
I don't see anything on here.
jit for eval?
Well, then what are you supposed to do
for training?
I actually hate like tricky puzzles
disguised as programming generally. Like
not something I enjoy at all.
They have examples. They have a
showcase,
but these don't look like examples.
Uh
is the
Wait, is Is jit not for training? I'm
confused.
Jet is only for the forward pass. Well,
it doesn't work at the moment because
this apparently
If I run it like this, this breaks.
So they they had this for the forward
pass, but like this breaks the backward
pass.
Um
And this should be on the docks.
There you go.
So, you want to jet
Emnist is on the docks.
Didn't see links to all these samples
unless I'm blind.
They do have examples.
Exactly what I want.
Oh, they actually have Muan in here
already.
Good job on that to them.
Okay, there we go. That's way better at
least. What autocomplete are you using?
Super Maven, which you can no longer get
as a new user. Cursor bought it and
killed it. And um
a few of us users bitched enough on
Twitter that they say that they're going
to continue supporting it for existing
users, which is props to them on that,
but I wish they would release the model.
I trust Grock to not mess this up
Just
uh you only can compile the model
forward pass with torch normally, right?
let's not have it mess with it like I
can
256 iterations just to get
this is a very small model.
Oh, that changes a lot, doesn't it?
All right, that does change it a lot.
So, it's possibly it could just be
caching something stupid, right?
I don't know if that's 110. That might
be fake, man.
That might be fake.
It can't be fake, right?
cuz it's Yeah, there's nothing for it to
cache
cuz it's the weights are changing so it
has to be real. Okay.
If this just keeps going up though, then
it's cheating
somehow.
I don't know. That's not like a
necessarily unreasonable speed.
But like why the thing is you're missing
the point, right? It shouldn't be that
much of a difference.
Yeah, but what could it possibly be
caching?
It has a fresh model, right? It's
running the optimizer on the model.
Okay, now it doesn't need a whole bunch
of iterations to warm up. There's some
noise to it.
Okay. So, 5 mil SPS at a tiny grad
unless I have the calc wrong.
It's weird. It's exactly one.
Okay, it's not exactly one. Cool. Uh, do
this.
Then we can check torch eager mode.
which I've actually I've seen this
happen fairly often.
I mean that sounds cool until you
realize that you're actually running
like
a billion is G. So you're running like I
don't know 02 or 03 teraflop something
like that.
Well, with two parameters like that's
not even speed, dude.
It's like, yeah, it's very easy to get
like it's very easy to get 14 bill SPS
with like 0% hardware utilization.
hovering from dying from your
experiences.
All right. This guy is just uh not too
bright, it seems.
So, what do we do with this? Um, it's 3x
slower than torch eager.
Most control problems you can solve with
under. Okay. Yeah, cuz go try that on
neural MMO 3.
Let's go look a little bit into the uh
the rest of the tiny red docks.
And where in the docks am I supposed to
be looking?
There's a section. Why so slow?
Is it?
Are you messing with me?
Oh.
Oh, okay. I didn't for whatever reason I
didn't cuz the showcase was under quick
start. Okay,
here. Let me read this
simple model.
We aren't syncing the GPU.
The GPU time may be slower.
I just so happened to remember that one.
That's not on them.
I was going to say they need better
error messages, but that one's really
not on them.
Okay. I mean, obviously I got to test
versus this now.
apparently this is actually faster than
Torch. This is not unusual for Torch, by
the way. This is not me doing something
wrong. Um, it is actually very often
that Torch is just somehow faster in
eager mode with small models than it is
in compile mode. Torch is kind of
stupid.
I don't know what the [ __ ] they do.
We'll give them the benefit of the
doubt. We'll try their defaults as well.
Yeah. So, you see, literally,
literally, um, Torch is slower with
compile on. And I've had everybody tell
me, "Oh, you're doing it wrong. You're
doing it wrong." But no, I've run like a
dozen different tests on a ton of
different versions of Torch in different
machines, and Torch Compile is just dog
[ __ ] That's simply what it is.
Um, hey mechanics, welcome. This is
actually one of the reasons I wanted to
move stuff into uh C++ with uh Puffer
was because I just didn't want to deal
with torch compile anymore because it's
just so bad. It's like actually
worthless.
yeah, we're now getting, you know, a
small but that's appreciable speed up
here. Um, this is not like, oh, yay,
time to use tiny. This is like, okay,
Tiny has passed the first test. Now,
let's go implement a real model with
Tiny and see whether Tiny is good, you
know, versus torch with a real model.
Uh, we're going to do Mingru.
I might just do like one layer Mr. H.
We'll see. I would like it to be pretty
close to the model that I use or I
intend to use in Puffer for.
And I think we can do it. I have uh I've
got Thanksgiving to go to in about an
hour 10. Let me fill up my coffee and we
will uh we'll get started.
Yep. The only thing that I will say is a
little bit obnoxious here is that um you
essentially you need to use their
version of Max Autotune to get the
result. Like their normal JIT is
disgustingly slow for these models.
So that's a little bit disappointing,
right? like you shouldn't have to search
kernels to beat the defaults. I wouldn't
think,
but then I don't know. I guess
Okay,
welcome everybody. Happy Thanksgiving.
Oh yeah, for everybody who's um who's
new around here, this is a special
stream today, but I kind of stream all
of my dev. So if you're interested in
high performance reinforcement learning,
all open source, check out puffer.ai and
feed that puffer a star. Helps me a ton.
We got tons of demos here. We got
discord.gg/puffer.
Um we got tons of educational materials
as well. And this is pretty much just
cutting edge research done in public.
All right.
Now, what we're going to do
Now, we're going to replace this model
with mining group, which I already have
an implementation of in here, and I just
have to modify up a little bit.
We're going to modify this, you know, a
little bit at least.
not a grew, it's a min.
So if you have not heard of this
architecture before, it's pretty cool.
So it is a linear time recurrence
architecture, which means that it can
take hidden state and give you next
hidden state. So it can have memory, but
you can actually train it in parallel.
So you can do all of the matrix
multiplications for the entire sequence,
even though it has hidden state in
parallel, which is pretty cool.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to just make like a super simple
version of this or like a super compact
version of this. Um,
and then we're going to get this ported
to Tiny.
Uh, this expansion factor is moderately
annoying, I believe.
No, actually, it's fine.
Would you ever show an end to end on how
to train something with puffer and see
it play? Not sure how to see the
behavior.
Yeah, it's super easy. Profiler and
debugger. Not yet. E10. Um, I'm first of
all, I just I don't need the breakdown
until I get a basic overall speed.
That's going to be the uh the plan.
Pay no attention to this 2 mil SPS. This
is like super dev mode stuff on 40.
It'll be way faster than this.
The goal for Puffer 40 is 10 million
step per second training. And I really
don't think I'm going to release it
until I hit that because I know it is
possible. Uh it just is going to take
some engineering.
I already have like a few of the final
kernels pretty well done as well. It's
just um the vectorization and like a
couple more kernels, few other
optimizations here and there.
current bottleneck uh vectorization's
eating like threeish mil SPS and I don't
know what I'm going to do about RMS norm
because I need that and that's super
slow.
Um
there's colonel launch overhead.
Okay. So,
uh,
convert, would you mind showing him? I
wanted to just show him here really
quick, but I forgot that I don't have um
loading working on Huffer 4 because I'm
on the dev branch at the moment and I
don't have it working from Python.
If Tiny is good for you, will you port
everything to it? I'd say that's fairly
unlikely, Danielle, unless apparently
there is a um a Torch front end. So, if
my users can't tell the difference, then
maybe. Um, I think the far more likely
thing is that we use their kernel gen,
but we will see.
Yeah, I was going to show you Hyper, but
I I'm kind of on the in the middle of
this dev branch.
What happened to default? Yeah, and I
got to focus because I only have an hour
to do this.
Right.
So this mining group code is not good or
anything. Right. This is like mostly
ported from um random lucid rain
implementation.
And I don't think we need this, right? I
think I can just steal this encoder off.
Yeah, I can totally just steal this
encoder off like this.
default decoder and all I need is
I need this one. No, not continuous
here.
This one.
Okay, this is self decoder.
to self value.
I'm going to swap the relus to g uh the
gus to relus. I think
I guess we'll see what operations um
tiny has built in.
we'll get rid of the puffer and it just
for simplicity. today.
There we go.
And then this will just be called
tiny model.
Uh, no, we actually will just replace
this.
true and then in uh this is output size
input size
output size hidden size
R2.
We just do BTX
Not enough values,
right? So, we have to change this
to a sequence model.
Uh, so I guess actually we can make this
way easier
because the only thing we'll really
going to care about is
we mostly care about this eval pass,
right?
got to be some simpler way we can test
this stupid thing, right?
I suppose for now the quickest thing is
just going to be to take
the OBS.
Does this get initial state? It does.
Uh,
yes.
Oh, is the model not on the right
device?
Try this.
Cool.
I think this is good enough.
Do the forward pass.
Okay. And this is not remotely the right
number of flops.
We can just get SPS out of this for now,
right?
Okay,
so here we have our current mining group
implementation, right?
We've got our synchronize
benchmark
synchronize
Should
be good.
dismissing the RMS. norm.
Uh, how is this missing the RMS norm?
Hold on.
No, it's not. We have the RMS norm in
here. Good.
Now we want to implement this exact same
thing in tiny.
Uh so this will be the question is how
hard is this All right.
The first thing we want is
Einstein associative scan.
Uh we can go grab a couple things from
go grab a few of these things, right?
like this is all the same
except
we have to do this.
Tensor of elements selected from either
X or Y
depending on self.
return x0
where like this right
Hello Rowey, welcome.
You can't do that. Um,
let's say soft plus.
Oh,
I see. They probably just made it so you
can do
tensor.soft
plus. They probably just do it like
this, right?
You can just do from tiny grad import
tensor as f probably
and it'll work.
Too much rely on vibe coding. You don't
learn things that way.
I don't want to do everything that way
though, Liberty. Like I actually like
the long chains of ops that way as your
only model of doing stuff is not great.
So yeah, I think what we're going to do,
right, and actually this is going to end
up looking exactly like torch
functional,
uh, which is fine.
So they're using I if I'm not wrong I
thought of this before. I don't think I
ever had a reason to implement this in
anything with puffer but I'll show you
something kind of cool. So you can call
you can call functions of a class um in
Python and you can pass self explicitly.
Does that make sense? So if you have
like if tensor has a method that is soft
plus you can call capital tensor.soft
plus and pass it a tensor as that self
arc. So you basically the way python is
written you kind of get a um a
procedural API for free
or functional API whatever
more procedural API I guess.
Yeah procedural API. So actually
uh this
thing here.
I can actually delete these.
And I think I can just do fware.
And I think that this works.
And now it shouldn't be f, right? Like
I'd actually think it would be pretty
cool if these were just in the tiny grab
space. You could just do like tiny.
um but I'm actually I'm way happier with
this now because this is going to be
I'm this is going to be virtually
identical is my hope.
I think this is going to be virtually
identical. You get rid of this.
So this is now
what do they call? They say
So, there are no biases with this, but
we'll just let that slide for now.
So, we'll just do uh self.2 hidden and
out is going to be tensor linear.
And this is just dim
dim inner times two.
You don't need a bias
Uh this out is going to be obnoxious and
we're not going to use it anyways for
this. So in the interest of time since I
have limited time today
not going to do this. And then let's
see, do they have RMS norm?
They even have linear.
Oh, they actually do have linear.
So, we should just use this
Yeah, this actually is going to be way
easier than expected.
So, this is I guess what they mean by
their torch compatible API.
Give it a torch.
They should have the docks linked easier
than that. Um
Oh, look. They literally Yeah. So, it's
just like this. And then where's the
device?
Is this not on GPU
or is it on GPU by default?
It's going to be under tensor, right?
So, it's probably going to be like under
F.
put output hidden.
Cool.
Um, what are you supposed to do about
this?
llvm context beam equals 2.
So wait, it's not it wasn't executing on
CPU before, was it?
Okay. So there I don't think they have
the sequential.
Oh, wait. They do.
F. Sequential.
day is not exactly typical. Pretty easy
so far. I'm actually I'm pres so it's
going to take me longer than just a
couple hours obviously of playing with
it. I thought I was going to have more
time today. I didn't know that I was
going to have um Thanksgiving was at 2.
Uh,
I don't know. But, um, at least this
gives me like so far I've been
pleasantly surprised and there hasn't
really been anything that's clearly, oh,
this is just bad, which that's a lot
coming from me.
Well, I mean, I don't know, convert.
There's like there's some stuff I've
heard with tiny. Like, if I just look at
Let's see if it's gotten better.
Oh, this is exactly what I want a
library to look like, actually.
I don't know why you write code like
this, right?
I guess. Uh does Python force you? No,
it really doesn't.
It's kind of a little golfy for my
liking,
you know.
Reduce must support
iteration. Okay, so I actually don't
know then.
They have a proper sequential in this.
Golfy means that they kind of lost track
of the goal of like keep it as simple as
possible and they start like putting a
lot of [ __ ] on one line just to make it
shorter when it doesn't actually make it
easier to read.
That's basically the only that was the
one thing kind of putting me off, you
know, um from the source. But then like
the thing is slightly gy
um beats the hell out of the monstrosity
of the torch code base. Like the torch
codebase is just [ __ ] bad.
Like there's no excuse for it. It's just
like the worst excesses of big tech
writing 10 times the amount of code they
need for absolutely everything.
You literally can't even find operations
in that codebase half the time.
I mean they named this thing sequential.
So I mean presumably
Ah
okay. Okay, they don't exactly have the
same type of sequential,
but that's fine. You know, I really
don't need it.
Not having module list on the other
hand. Oh well wait, you don't need it.
Lol. It's literally Yeah, you don't need
module list. Dare.
That's a torch thing because torch is
dumb. I forgot about that. Okay, I'm
happy.
Uh not callable because it is does not
forward function
Oh, we need state
state.
Does anybody know is this thing on GPU
by default in Tinyrad?
I think if I end up using this I this
would have to be really good for me to
like swap PyTorch completely. I think if
that happens I have to just order
another server from the guy out of
principal.
I technically have uh the funds
bookmarked for it anyways at some point.
He actually, it was kind of funny. So,
when I was having trouble with my boxes,
like he sent me like a bunch of pictures
of him taking apart the tiny box just
like in 10 minutes. Like, you [ __ ]
imbecile. Like, how the [ __ ] can you not
take this box apart after several hours?
And I had to tell him like, "Dude, the
front panel on mine didn't come off like
the front panel came off on yours. It
took a 100 pounds of force and then it
freaking warped the metal." I'm not
doing it wrong. This case was just
[ __ ]
And there were a few other things as
well.
He's like, "All right, guy thinks I'm
eating glue or something.
We need the warranty."
They don't really have much of a
warranty in the first place, dude.
Hey Spencer, it's surprisingly so far so
good.
Like surprisingly pretty damn good so
far.
What happens if I put this break point
inside? Does it work or does it break
because of the jet? If this works, I
will be impressed
that they thought of this.
So, I mean, this definitely kicks the
[ __ ] out of Jacks.
Now whether this is the end all be all
is uh we shall see.
I've just been testing tiny out, man.
with like small models and seeing how
good it is.
Pretty much what I've been up to
step
eight.
What did you break point and saw it hit
a state line? Oh, that I was just happy
that the fact that it doesn't it doesn't
break your uh debugging when you have
JIT on, but I put a break point inside
of something that has a JIT decorator on
and it didn't break.
Like basically everything torch breaks
if you do that. I think jacks breaks if
you do that
I just I I honestly just hate everything
about that. like framework. Jax is just
like it's like such a Google thing as
well. It's like the oh we are so clever.
Look, we came up with this whole new way
to write code and like and like wo and
behold us and it's just garbage every
[ __ ] time.
like there's not enough there aren't
enough real problems to solve at Google
or something. So, they come up with
problems so that they have problems to
solve. I don't know.
I mean like all you have to do like I
had to be like to their credit I had the
um I think the flax dev yeah the flax
dev messaged me like hey I saw your post
you know what can we do better and it's
like I try to be nice right because it's
like okay you're trying to build stuff I
can always appreciate that but like look
when I look at an RL codebase by
somebody who I know is actually good and
they're writing seven nested functions
and your framework is basically pushing
ing people to write seven nested
functions and every repo is like this
even by people who I know write good
code. Your framework sucks.
I can always appreciate people trying to
like actually caring and like trying to
build stuff. It's just like at some
point there's just such a big gap.
It's just very difficult, you know.
int args.
Star args tensor.
Oh
man, why do you do it this way?
They're like a couple of these like
really annoying discrepancies.
I don't know. I I think the whole
functional thing is like an overreaction
to object-oriented programming being
[ __ ] and then it's like they just went
and made something somehow even worse.
Just like not if you just like delete
inheritance and delete. Okay, there's
actually to be fair there's a lot of
stuff you need to delete.
Just go write some C. You'll figure it
out.
int object. I will say that their error
messages here are quite confusing.
Yeah, their error messages could be
better.
Oh, you know why
that's super annoying, man?
They made it a mandatory keyword arg.
Okay, this is this is actually a pet
peeve now. They're kind of using they're
using some of the lesser known features
of Python cuz like this is a mandatory
so this is like now a mandatory keyword
arg. So if you actually pass it without
the keyword, you're going to get the
wrong result.
I almost can't fault him for it. It's
like
just freaking pass it as a tpple though.
Honestly,
I don't know. I'm usually in favor of
just like not using every single damn
fancy feature in the language.
Like star args. Okay. Like star args
with keyword arg.
The one that's really bad is you can
just put a star like before keyword args
without having star args and then it'll
also be mandatory keyword args. There
like a bunch of weird things you can do
in Python technically that like doesn't
mean you should necessarily
now. We're going to actually I think for
the real PF comparisons, it's going to
be a bit more work,
but this was a good start.
So, things I've learned so far. Um, it
seems like there is some hope of this
actually being reasonably fast. Um, it's
basically identical to torch. So, this
is something that I almost wouldn't feel
too bad uh providing for users if it's
like almost identical.
And I have really good reason for it.
Um, and apparently they can do kernel
gen and stuff. So, we might be able to
do some stuff with that as well. I think
it's going to take a lot more
investigation, but this is so far the
first couple hours I've spent with this
is enough that it's worth spending
another couple hours and then we will uh
we will see from there. All right. So,
this is
Yeah, we will have to see from there. Um
I've got to go get ready for
Thanksgiving.
So, um for folks who've tuned in, happy
Thanksgiving. I might stream this later.
I might take the evening off. I think
people are going to probably be doing
Thanksgiving things anyways for the most
part. So, I'll probably just pick this
up either tomorrow or maybe Saturday,
you know, depends on what I'm feeling
like. We'll see. Um, but if you're
interested in my stuff generally,
everything I do here is all free. It's
all open source at puffer.ai. The only
way this project makes money is through
um contracts with larger companies that
want to get the best out of our tools
that want custom sim and stuff like
that. Um everyone else, all our stuff is
right here. Free open source. Start the
repo helps feed the puffer. Join the
Discord if you want to get involved with
dev. And you can follow me on X for more
reinforcement learning content. I post
educational stuff once in a while. We've
got a nice collection of articles,
different topics,
and yeah, that's going to be about it.
So, thank you. See you around.